آه ، لقد
اعتقدت حرفيًا أنني سأموت ، ألا
تعرف أن
هناك الكثير من الأطباء والأشياء
هناك ، جيس كيلي تدق ناقوس الخطر
حول كيف أن ساعتها Apple قد أنقذت
حياتها وحياة طفلتها الجديدة التي
كنت أرقدها  السرير ليس على ما يرام ،
لم أكن أعرف ما إذا كان
مرضي الصباحي يعود إلى الثلث الثالث من الحمل
أو إذا كان ذلك بسبب إصابتي
بأنفلونزا معدة ابني ولذا لم أكن أمارس
أي نوع من النشاط لذلك اعتقدت أنه أمر
غريب حقًا  كان يخبرني أن
معدل ضربات قلبي كان يتخطى 120 نبضة في
الدقيقة ، ولا
تزال أم كوستا ميسا أمامها بضعة أسابيع
حتى موعد استحقاقها ، وتقول إن
ساعتها آبل استمرت في النقيق عليها أن
معدل ضربات قلبها كان مرتفعًا وظهر هذا التحذير
على الشاشة  الأمر الذي زاد من
مخاوفها ، فقد اختفى أه في
المرة الأولى وظننت أنه غريب ثم
المرة الثانية ربما بعد 10 دقائق
أو نحو ذلك ثم المرة الثالثة التي أعتقد أنها
ربما كانت بعد نصف ساعة أو نحو ذلك
وعندما انفجرت  في
المرة الثالثة التي اعتقدت فيها أن هناك شيئًا ما يحدث على ما يرام ،
ذهبت جيس كيلي مباشرة إلى المستشفى
وهو بالضبط ما أوصى به الدكتور بريان كولسكي
لا يعالج طبيب القلب في بروفيدنس سانت جوزيف هذه الأم ولكن
لديه مرضى يصفون لهم
ساعات أبل للكشف عن بعض
أمراض القلب  يبدو أنه كان دقيقًا وإحدى
العلامات الأولى عندما
يكون الناس في مأزق ما إذا كان
نزيف ضغط الدم هو ارتفاع
معدل ضربات القلب وصلت كيلي في المخاض الكامل وكان
ضغط دمها ينخفض
وكانت تفقد الدم بسبب
مضاعفات الحمل المعروفة  نظرًا لانفصال المشيمة
بعد ثلاث ساعات ،
ولدت شيلبي ماري طفل سليم ، فهي ممتنة جدًا
للأطباء والممرضات ولساعة آبل الخاصة بها ،
استمع إليها ، إنها ليست مجرد
رسالة نصية تعرفها
أو تعلم أنها تساعدك في العثور على
تنبيه هاتفك بل يجب أن تدفع  الانتباه إليها
والاستماع إلى جسدك في
أخبار Costa Mesa Michelle gelly KCAL